i'm choosing this article from
willamette week on purpose
because willamette week is my
understanding
fairly biased and even they're forced to
admit straight up the oregon state
police will now provide
protection for free speech they caved
man
listen the demands from these leftists
in in portland was to defund the
portland police by 50 percent
the response the state is sending in
police
so it's not not only are they not
defunding portland police y'all getting
more
yeah 60 plus nights you know what the
democrats realized what
ted wheeler the other day said can we
negotiate a ceasefire oh yeah that's
right we talked about it yeah and i'm
like what under what authority do you
have to negotiate for
antifa like would you would it fire yes
ceasefire seriously no
no what he was actually saying is we
could crush these riots at any moment
we're now agreeing to do so let us know
what you want and i think the reason was
trump was looking good yep and they
didn't think it was gonna happen i think
they pulled the police out initially so
so early on the portland police were
engaging and deal and you know arresting
rioters
on the 39th night the feds sent in extra
dhs
troops because there were already
marshals there because of all the bad
press
about dhs portland police stopped they
issued a statement where they were like
we did not engage at all that wasn't us
we had nothing to do with this
and then that meant trump was the only
one dealing with this
eric weinstein he's the famous idw guy
said he tweeted he was hearing a lot
from liberals that there were two big
reasons they were jumping ship and you
know potentially voting for trump and
one
was biden's cognitive dissonance
cognitive dis uh decline decline well
there we go
i was trying to try to be nice decline
but the second was what he called
the experi experiment in non-policing in
places like portland over the riots yeah
how the police were backing down
then you look at trump's approval rating
it started to go up a little bit
especially with rasmussen
and then you see opposition to black
lives matter starting to go way way up
and they the democrats knew the black
lives that are protests the peaceful
ones
were great for them and that's true it
really does help democrats
so now with the police backing down and
violent riots riots sweeping across for
60 days
trump was the only one no it was only
trump and guess what regular people
don't riot don't protest and don't
sympathize with these people
so all they see is cops being attacked
and fighting and they're like
i don't like this craziness i just want
it to stop they should all be arrested
you know you know what's scary to me is
that a lot of these a lot of regular
americans don't care about civil
liberties
if it came down to it and you were
holding up a sign and marching through
their neighborhood
they'd probably just want you arrested
and kicked out immediately well there's
a
small town in colorado that that exactly
that that basically happened there was
maybe
10 black lives matter you know
protesters and man that the whole town
came out
and there was like the sheriff came with
horses there was like
six or seven horse horse officers
and like the whole town you just see
them like get out of our town
like here's your trash that you dropped
like take this with you and get out and
everyone's like
now that that's a real sheriff right
there and it's like whoa and there was
that
in ohio i think north colorado somewhere
in ohio like 70 black lives matter
protesters show up to the small town
and like 700 counter protesters came out
and they were like
we will crush you get out yep
regular americans don't don't don't want
to deal with this no they don't they
want to go to work they want to come
home
they want to ask you know talk to their
kids who their kids are up to you know
how school let's go play baseball or
whatever
these people are isolated in these
cities and they really don't get it so
let's
take a look at this article willamette
week says oregon governor kate brown
announced wednesday morning that
following discussions with vice
president mike pence
federal agents occupying the marco
hatfield federal courthouse in portland
have agreed to a phased withdrawal
the withdrawal will begin thursday july
30th brown said the federal agents will
also
clean up the building's exterior which
is covered in graffiti
so so maybe that's the one thing they
got we we will agree to all of your
demands so long as your guys clean up
the graffiti on your own building
they're like okay great send in the
police
they mentioned since early july officers
from federal agencies including uh dhs
customs and border protection
specialized vortech unit
have dispersed and injured protesters
of course is that it protesters who
congregated around the eight-foot black
fence that surrounds the courthouse all
right i got to stop you know i can't
stand this listen
the fence wasn't always up the fence was
put up
at some point in the past couple of
weeks so these riots have been going on
for quite some time
their presence in oregon garnered
national criticism
when oregon public broadcasting reported
federal agents were snatching protesters
into unmarked rental vans
how dumb snatching these federal
officers have acted as an occupying
force refused accountability and brought
violence and strife to our community
brown said in a statement
we have an opportunity that we we cannot
afford to waste the departure of federal
forces represents the beginning of a
process
that will be as difficult as it is
overdue oregon state police will arrive
at the building to provide protection
for free speech
and the security of the exterior of the
courthouse with the federal protective
service
well i hope they're there for the
security of the interior of the
courthouse also no the feds are going to
stay
oh inside yeah okay okay you know
there's that joke about like
aliens will come to earth and they go up
to the dog and say take us to your
leaders yeah yeah because they assume
we're serving them
right when if they're leading us if the
oregon state police
if if the feds are there and the oregon
government goes to the feds and say
we'll deploy police to protect you
oregon is providing a service to the
feds
i'm sorry the feds have clearly won this
one so here's here's actually what
happened in response to this
acting secretary chad wolf tweeted the
state of oregon is finally agreeing to
cooperate with our federal forces
exactly what we asked for since the
nightly violence broke out two months
ago
we're glad oregon is now correcting
their months-long error
why did they deploy dhs to the
courthouse because the police weren't
doing their job
boom and i i i i feel bad for some of
these cops to be honest
because their hands were being tied by
feckless democrats who are like but
you're making things worse by arresting
these violent thugs
i'm sorry peaceful protesters here
actually we have uh a
peaceful protest a fan of ours vince
sent us an actual picture of of peaceful
protesters
look at that it's actually a bunch of
stickers and things that this is this is
it's an image of a peaceful man in a
with a peaceful
bottle full of peaceful kerosene that's
a peace bottle a peace bottle
he's stretching it's you also light it
on fire and and throw it
um and it it causes fire but it's
peaceful it looks like he's doing yoga
but listen he's
you've got the intention all wrong you
see what you're supposed to do is when
there's someone clearly
cold yeah you throw it so it lands next
to them and you can warm them and they
can
you know it's an instant campfire bottle
there you go it's an instant campfire in
a bottle
very peaceful wow well here's here's
what chad wolfe says he goes on to say
we will maintain our current augmented
federal law enforcement personnel in
portland
until we are assured that the hatfield
federal courthouse and other federal
properties will no longer be attacked
and that the seat of justice in portland
will remain secure
dhs will not back down from our legal
duty to protect federal law enforcement
officers
and federal properties in the face of
violent criminal behavior potus made
clear
that that this administration is ready
and willing to partner with state and
local law enforcement to protect every
american
and you see that commitment in portland
with his plan
and then this person tweeted you got
smacked down
that's it amazing
absolutely amazing some people just
don't pay attention
you know what really really uh kind of
scares me about all of this
is that i think you know we've talked
about the different factions in the
culture war
it really does feel like mature adults
responsible adults and whiny children
that's that's what we're seeing yeah the
so you get these lunatics who come out
throwing bottles i mean we've see
we we we talked about those videos of
the women screaming like you wouldn't do
this to a nice young girl from
wisconsin or whatever young young woman
yeah it's
you you or that uh the video from new
york where the woman
screaming in the cop's face or effing
what all right she's going and pulls her
in and they just screaming
so let me let me explain let's check
this out the other day
coin king five seattle said mayor durkin
says federal agents have demobilized and
left seattle
seattle mayors confirmed the department
of homeland security border patrol
tactical unit is no longer in seattle
and it's funny because just the other
night she had given an interview to cnn
where she said trump was doing a dry run
for martial law
and like while she's saying it trump's
like all right get all the troops out
you know you know why they sent the law
the dhs into seattle
because they finally broke into the
courthouse right no in seattle oh oh
seattle no no
there were reports of potential violent
riots on saturday oh okay
so before saturday they were like okay
we're gonna send in some extra uh
law enforcement into the courthouses and
into our federal buildings
and then if the riots get out of hand
we'll have the extra support the weekend
passed
the riots were you know they were kind
of bad and the police handled some of
them
they didn't go to the courthouse so then
trump said okay or probably not even
trump is probably chad wolf was like all
right guess we didn't need them
back and so it's that simple you see a
sane rational
adult who's following the news goes ah
that's it ah makes sense
okay logic yeah yeah sure what but if
you read if you watch the news if you
watch the bill bar hearing what do you
get
they're just screwing emotions versus
logic exactly
yep but it's it's i mean what what is
the root of this
immaturity inability to calmly and
rationally
deduce what is actually going on true so
if i told you
oh hey there's going to be um there
there's there's fears there's going to
be a massive riot
saturday in seattle so they decided to
send an extra law enforcement just to
stay inside the federal courthouse
the response is huh that's it
i mean it means there's no there's no
kind of it's like okay they're and it's
preempted
you know interesting just in case but
you know the conversation they're having
is
donald trump is deploying his secret
police into all of our cities to
snatch people off the streets he's
stormtroopers
i know i know you saw this but i don't
know if everyone that's watching saw it
but
so the nypd did this now too they pulled
up in a minivan
and they they snatched someone up so it
turns out this person was destroying
cameras so they were looking for this
one specific person with a warrant
with a warrant and showed up that's that
person
oh they already released they released
them so so they they snatch this person
up and all i can see all i can say was
like i wonder how long it's going to
take for them to blame
it's already got 10 million views that
video yep of course
in the video a van pulls up to a march
they grab this tran it's a trans femme a
lot of
news outlets have said she her and and
woman okay but the activists literally
said transfem so i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna assume any pronouns i'm gonna use
exactly what the activists refer to this
individual as
okay and then as they snatch uh jump out
and and grab
it's the warrant squad nypd's warrant
squad using an unmarked van
and immediately nypd bike police form a
barrier around the van
in uniform with with bright yellow vests
reflective vests
standing there holding people back and
they're like who's kidnapping
our friend i i wonder who could it be
i wonder if that uh the big huge police
written across those reflective vests
it's not worth we're a clue into that no
if it wasn't enough in portland to say
these are police arresting you
then i don't i don't tell you now look
man there's
there's a good argument against the
abuse and overuse of plane clothes and
unmarked vehicles
i'm not a big fan i'm not either but to
act like it's
new and shocking is a lie definitely
no knock raids bad definitely no not
grades from plainclothes cops
even worse really bad and when a
plainclothes cop executes a no-knock
warrant and then the homeowner defends
himself
and they arrest the homeowner the worst
you could possibly get yep
absolutely no way there's a bunch of
stories like this yep where like the
cops will just
three in the morning kick your door in
you look out you look down the stairs
and there's a bunch of dudes and
t-shirts and jeans and you're like i'm
being robbed being invaded right yeah
they're attacking my home
and they don't identify themselves and
they do this and that's why we have a
lot of these stories like brianna taylor
or or duncan lent depending on which you
know
political faction you'll you know i
guess the boogaloo boys talk about all
of them because they don't care if the
government is killing people they're
killing people right
but that's that's that's the gist of it
okay if the police have unmarked
vehicles
they've always had unmarked vehicles
probably as long as vehicles have
existed to be honest
good point i have to imagine when the
first car was invented police weren't
like i know let's put our name big
big bold and sirens on top of this thing
i mean unless maybe they like could you
imagine horses like when they had horses
did they write police on the horse
i don't know no but they would wear a
badge but i don't think they wore
uniforms back then maybe they did i
don't know i don't know the history of
police to be honest
but i'd imagine that you know look
it's part of the narrative that the
activists are pushing
because it's all propaganda they'll show
you a small clip
and say they're kidnapping people and
then all of a sudden
every leftist pundit will just be like i
agree
and i'm like where did common sense go
this is the most it's the most annoying
thing to me
you know yeah it's well it's not gone
i'll tell you that
was never here no no no you have common
sense i have comments i'm talking about
lydia has common sense i have a little
right okay so the few people out there
that that we talk about a lot on the
show
seem to have a lack of a million views
on this video dude
yeah but it's not all i watched it it's
true you know we watched it
it's it's everyone who's being aware of
the situation or watching it too
npcs man a lot of people are real the
meme is real
yeah i believe that you turn on the tv
and you have npcs reporting news to npcs
and how do you break that you it's like
you can't do it yeah
you you have emotionally reactive
fervent zealous angry people
who don't care i don't understand how
you communicate with these people
right how do you get to them because i'm
i'm a fairly good
uh communicator i did non-profit
fundraising yeah but when you have
someone
who is just blinded with rage like their
eyes are glowing and they're just like
have like you know foaming at the mouth
how does how do even their own faction
communicate with them because they even
fight each other
it's like a chaotic destructive force
they've set their eyes on something they
want to be mad about
and they romp about angry maybe that's
it maybe they're mad at maybe maybe it's
just misdirected anger that's all it is
yep i agree each and every one of these
people was sitting at home
and they were like eating uh an ice
cream and then like the ice cream fell
off the cone and landed on the floor
and they march on the streets screaming
and they take it out on the police
that's the best i can think of yeah i
mean
this is the problem though there's never
one answer to anything
you know a lot of these these people on
the left they like to blame
one thing for all the problems you know
and that that
a lot of people do this they're like
this is the one thing that is messing up
everything instead of looking at
everything as a whole and that's the
problem we everyone needs to take a step
back and just look at
as you know the whole picture and a lot
of people are losing that
that ability they're so focused on this
one thing and then
that one thing pisses them off so they
can't even get
you know past that everything is about
that one thing and if you disagree about
that one thing
you're you're the enemy and you're evil
period no no questions
no talking i'll tell you what i think
school is a big part of the problem
definitely so so not to like
in my mind i'm thinking of a bunch of
things i don't want to jump too far
ahead but i'm thinking
one of the problems these people have is
they're they're linear thinkers
they can only focus on one thing at a
time i remember there was a
during occupy wall street everybody's
sitting around talking about the demands
should be
and some person you know one person was
like it's wall street they're the
problem everyone argued
then finally some old dude just snapped
and stood up and said
what is wrong with you people why can't
you understand
the one problem is fracking and i was
like
what oh and that's because
they're linear it's it's a it's a linear
and and
you know myopic thought process they see
one thing like you were saying yeah
and that's the only thing they can see
and there's no subtlety there's no
nuance there's no uh there's no
conversation
it's just i know the only problem is
this and then you're like man and then
they go
they go to the crusades on against
everyone for that
one thing and that's all they want to
talk about that's all that
it doesn't matter what other other
things you bring in any other logical
conversations that relate to it no no
that doesn't matter because
this one thing that's all that matters
and this is why
i was talking about schools it's like i
think in kindergarten
the most important thing we can teach
kids chess
okay interesting make you play chess as
a kid i did
me too well i i started i was being
taught chess before i was a
when i was like a mindless non-english
speaking baby
my mom and uh you know her friends were
showing me the chess pieces and
explaining it while i was going
so as long as i can remember that makes
a lot of sense though yeah and then
the brain works and then magic the
gathering so then when i was like seven
for those that aren't familiar with
magic it's a strategy card game
it's it's uh we we call it like what
chess and poker combined
yeah it's a turn-based strategy game but
it's got
instead of how many pieces are in chess
i don't know
i don't know i have no idea 13 12. uh
magic has 20 000 cards it's become
ridiculously complicated it's the most
complicated game
way more than 20 000 yeah way more so
when i was younger i started playing
you know magic and and pokemon and other
you know card games but it was all about
strategy so
when you're looking at your opponent
you're playing strategy games you don't
know the cards they're holding
and you have to try and calculate the
likelihood of certain cards they might
have to use against you
so your one problem in this battle
against your opponent
there's no one problem they're holding
seven cards and you're like
any one of those seven cards could be
one of seven you know seven i know they
have that could end this game for me
whereas you get these kids who grow up
not doing any complex thought or
critical thinking
and honestly snow plow parents clearing
everything out in front of them
and then what happens they grow up and
they're sitting in their apartment and
they're like
i'm unhappy i don't know why i'm just
angry
and then along comes someone who goes
howdy friend i see that you're angry
how would you like an easy fix i can
just give you something to be angry
about
hey that sounds great how about this
cause
and they're like that's the one thing
i'll choose to be angry about all i can
think is john cleese
exactly the john so i don't know if you
guys have seen the uh
john cleese very famous i i i think it
was a monty python sketch
uh yeah i don't know where he's like if
you are uh generally like i don't know
the whole line but if you want to be
angry at something
just join a cause you can be on the far
left and then there's
all these people that you get to blame
for everything the corporations
the government you know and of course
moderates yeah and then he's like and if
you want to be on the extreme right then
you can talk about
immigration you can talk about you know
labour party and of course
moderates it's funny like they're always
mad at moderates yeah
yeah but that it's it's amazing how that
skit really does
circle back today perfectly oh yeah it's
it hits the nail on the head
but anyway to to the the broader point
you know i look at people who can't
actually fathom that there are multiple
layers to their problems
and so all they here's what you get you
get people who march in the street
who scream capitalism is the problem or
white supremacy
and they can't actually define any of it
properly that's true then
you'll see a bunch of people democratic
politicians who go hmm
well you can't reason with them but you
can make money off them i'll tell them i
agree capitalism is bad vote for me and
then i get paid
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode